Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricard Lops, and
today I'm joined by Dr. Seamus Power. He's associate
professor of cultural psychology at the University of Copenhagen,
and today we're going to talk about his book
Inequality, A View from Manywhere. So Dr. Power, welcome
to the show. It's a pleasure to everyone.
Thanks so much, Ricardo. It's lovely to be here.
OK, so it's interesting because in your book, uh,
of course, you also talk about the economic side
of things, but since you are a psychologist, you,
of course, tackle economic inequality mostly from a psychological
pers. Perspective. So, what is the psychology of economic
inequality? I mean, in what ways do you approach
economic inequality as a psychologist and perhaps in what
ways does it differ from how economists approach it?
Yeah, it's a great question to start off, and
as you said in your introduction, I'm a cultural
psychologist, so which itself is a transdisciplinary enterprise somewhere
between psychology but inspiration from other disciplines like anthropology,
philosophy, history, sociology, and so on. So it's kind
of a social scientific discipline. So I'm kind of
located in this space, and of course the book
is about. Economic inequality and capitalism. So traditionally, when
people think about economic inequality, they're talking about differences
between individuals and groups and nations in terms of
the wealth accumulation, uh, and income as well. So,
economists tend to really speak about this topic quite
a lot, uh, of inequality and growing inequality and
the separation, um, of different social Groups and nations
as well. Uh, AND little has been done, um,
from a psychological point of view, a cultural psychological
point of view. So I wanted to kind of
bring that lens onto one of these topics, uh,
that's really definitional for the lives of, of almost
everyone on the planet, at least hundreds of millions
of people really think and care about this topic
of inequality and stories of growing inequality as well.
But how would you say it differs from how
economists approach economic inequality?
Yeah, sure. I mean, so what I'm interested in
is people's subjective understandings of economic inequality, above and
beyond objective indicators of GDP per capita, GNP and
these types of um um data that economists are
typically interested in. So I'm kind of interested in
how people think about, feel, experience, um, economic inequality
and the economic systems in which they live. So
I think that's the kind of fundamental differences jump
between objective and subjective.
And what are the most common views that people,
I mean people, when I mean people, I mean
both regular laypeople and economists have about economic inequality.
Yeah, I mean, there's lots of discussion, um, maybe,
you know, since Piketty and his kind of his
book Capitalism in the 21st Century really put this
issue of economic inequality back on the agenda of
academics and the public as well in 2014. Basically,
the idea that's been perpetrated from this is this
idea that the rich are getting richer and leaving
the rest of us behind. So this is kind
of, at least in the academic. World and social
science, uh, economics and psychology. This is what people
tend to focus on, this idea that the rich
are getting richer, and this has this, uh, downstream,
uh, consequences for much of humanity. Um, SO this
is, this is mainly how it's thought about in
social science. Uh, WE hear a lot about it
in the media as well. Left-wing media pick up
this narrative as well. But when you think about
it globally as well, I mean, there's of course
issues to do with economic inequality, but one of
the issues I Also addressed in the book is
this idea of poverty, uh, and hundreds of millions
of people who live and die in poverty all
around the world. And again, you know, at certain
periods of history, these ideas of poverty and poverty
reduction, uh, make the headlines and people talk about
it in the kind of Western academic world and
so on, uh, but often they're forgotten. And one
of the arguments in the book is that we
have forgotten and we ought not to forget, uh,
poverty throughout the world as well when we talk
about inequality.
And in the book you talk about two main
global stories, I mean the most dominant global stories
that seem to contradict each other when it comes
to economic inequality and that we hear about in
politics and the media. So what are those two
stories?
Yeah, I mean this is this kind of narration
of these two stories, which takes up a good
chunk of part one of the book and echoes
throughout the rest of the book. The other two
parts are about these kind of two conflicting stories
of economic inequality. On the one hand, we have
this kind of dominant story we hear a lot
about in the academy and then maybe left wing
media and politics. AS well, the rich are getting
richer, leaving us all behind, as I've stated, right?
So this is kind of an omnipresent, uh, uh,
argument. And of course people from different disciplines feed
into this, whether it's economics, psychology, anthropology, and so
on. Uh, SO this is kind of wooden bucket
of, of narratives that kind of, uh, can be
combined in this master narrative. But then on the
other hand, I mean, there's another Story that's perhaps
less popular to talk about, but it's this idea
that despite economic inequalities between people, groups, and societies,
that actually in a relatively short historical period of
time, capitalism has lifted hundreds of millions of people
out of abject poverty. It's created abundance and prosperity.
That's, yes. Uh UNEQUALLY shared, but still on a,
in a relatively short period of historical time, uh,
the world has gotten far more prosperous than it
has before. So, you know, I mean, there's so
many things written across disciplines and philosophy, economics, social
science, and so on about economic inequality. This kind
of idea of creating these two master narratives, I
thought was an interesting way to kind of frame
the book, um, and, and to create these two
narratives.
Right, so from a psychological perspective, I guess that
one of the main things that plays a role
here in terms of how people look at economic
inequality has to do with fairness, right? And of
course, uh, I mean there's a philosophical aspect which
we could discuss here whether it's fair. Or not
for economic inequality to even exist or what is
a fair level of economic inequality and if rich
people or whatever level of richness we're talking about,
uh, millionaires, billionaires, whether they really deserve that kind
of wealth. And, and, and if people who are
at the bottom of, uh, bottom of the socio-economic
hierarchy really uh deserve such a fate, I mean,
really deserve to be poor and things like that,
but from a psychological perspective, uh, how do people
perceive, uh, fairness?
Yeah, I mean, I think that's a really interesting
question. One of the kind of key psychological ideas
in the book is this discussion of fairness and
the kind of multiple meanings that people have of
fairness. I mean, there's also a long literature in
psychology about this. You probably know the work of
Jonathan Haidt. He and I share some kind of
lineage at the University of Chicago and his book
The Righteous Mind. He also talks quite a lot
about Fairness. Uh, HE approaches it from an evolutionary
psychology perspective, which I also think is interesting and
shared with other people like Paul Bloom as well
and moral developmental psychology. But making this kind of
argument between them that there's kind of an ingrained
sense of fairness of proportionality in the distribution of
goods between people. Uh, WHICH I think is particularly
interesting, right? It's kind of like in our nature
to kind of think about ideas of fairness and
how things are distributed in the proportionality. But what
John does and, and, and so on and others
as well who work in, in kind of cultural
nature of morality and the cultural reasoning of morality
is to show and to think about how ideas
of fairness, um, vary across cultural context and across
time. And that's when, you know, the evolutionary kind
of basis, uh, meets the cultural psychology, um. And
how it manifests, uh, non-uniformly across time. But then
when it comes to, for example, uh, income inequality
and wealth inequality, you know, the consequence of this
kind of theorizing is that, yeah, sure, people have
this, uh, something that they feel in the gut
about a sense of fairness and what's right and
wrong when it comes to the distribution of abundance
or wealth, income, and so forth. Uh, BUT it's
varied radically, uh, throughout the world, as you've already
hinted at with your, with your question. So ideas
of fairness and how things should be. Redistributed very
differently in Chicago, for example, where I did my
PhD, uh, versus in Copenhagen, where I'm a faculty
member. It's very different cultural worlds and very different
ways of thinking about economic inequality and the sharing
and redistribution of wealth, uh, as well. So I
kind of, in the book, I take this cultural
psychological lens, uh, to try and understand, uh, how
people think about fairness and different kind of lay
theories of fairness and redistribution that underscore different cultural
contexts around the world.
So referring to the subtitle of your book, what
is the view from many wars? What do you
mean by that?
Yeah, I mean, I have to give credit to
Richard Schrader, who I know has been on your
program before. Uh, Rick was my grad school advisor
in Chicago and for my postdoc, and this is
something that really permeated his work as a cultural
anthropologist and a cultural psychologist and all his teaching
and mentorship as well. So I definitely have to
give credit to Rick for uh for the subtitle.
But basically the view from many words is this
kind of poetic attempt to frame a philosophical position
where One stays on the move between multiple points
of view in an effort to seek out something
fundamental about a phenomena of interest. In my case,
I'm writing about inequality and what the pursuit of
a view from many words is, is to try
and stand the move between multiple disciplines. So in
the book, there's discussions of, you know, economic theory,
there's philosophical foundations, there's mainstream experimental social psychology evidence.
There's cultural psychology, ethical. Graphic works, there's discussions of
anthropologists, so you get this kind of broad transdisciplinary
view and different insights from different disciplinary perspectives. Uh,
THERE'S methodological differences as well, um, between different sources
of data. There's big data, economic data sets. There's
more lived experience, phenomenological accounts, and almost everything in
between is reported in the, in the book as
well. So again, to try and have this kind
of holistic understanding from it. And then the third
kind of aspect of many words beyond the theories
and disciplines and the methodologies is also, as we've
already kind of talked about a little bit, is
to stay on the move between these different stories
and different kind of political and ideological viewpoints as
well. One where we complain that the rich are
getting richer, leaving us behind, and then the other
narrative, for example, uh, where, uh, capitalism, uh, despite
inequality has led to prosperity.
But in this view from many wars, could, uh,
I mean, aspects of those two different sides of
the debate still play a role here, but then
we can expand on them, or how does it
work, or should we just leave the more ideological
aspects of the debate completely aside?
Yeah, I mean, I think, you know, one of
the motivations for writing the book is that I
see a lot of kind of writing and discussion
of economic inequality and capitalism and the future of
capitalism, uh, being particularly polarized, right? That someone kind
of puts a flag in the ground and you
just want to argue from this one particular viewpoint.
They marshal evidence to support this viewpoint and really
don't engage on the other side, right? So we
see it across disciplines, across methods, and then across
topics. Uh, SO I guess one of the innovations
and novelties of the book is, again, to try
and stay on the move between these multiple points
of view, to seek out a more holistic understanding.
So I do try to put these two narratives,
for example, from part one of the book, in
conversation with each other, and then to assess the
scopes and limits and to take seriously the arguments
from either side of it, to take a moderate.
POSITION to look at the evidence, to look at
the uh uh how convincing arguments are, what are
the blind spots, and so on. But really, you
know, that's part two of the book is kind
of that assessment. But part three, which I guess
we'll talk about, but part three is to try
and create a new story of capitalism and economic
development into the future, uh, from presenting these two
stories. So the, the hope and the aim of
the book is to um is to really take
seriously, uh, this view for many words to take
seriously, uh, multiple different perspectives and arguments, uh, and
to narrate them in a way that's engaging, I
hope, for the reader, uh, and then to form
something new from the serious engagement.
OK, so let's talk a little bit about the
data then and the data that support each of
these two different views. So what are, what are
the best data out there that support the view
that the wealthy are becoming increasingly wealthier to the
detriment of most of humanity?
Yeah, I mean, I think there's multiple different data
sources. I draw a lot on Thomas Piketty and
the work of his group and his collaborators around
the world, from also from the Oxford-based resource Our
World in Data that provide this kind of really
lovely open access sort of data that people use
throughout the world, which is really interesting. So I
think, you know, those people have done incredible work
compiling these very Interesting data sets and making them
accessible to different researchers from different fields, but also,
of course, the journalists and policymakers as well. So
I think between our world and data, Max Roser,
uh, who's the, the director of this, um, institute,
as well as Piketty, um, and his World Inequality
Lab, um, these are the kind of big data
that I draw on. I mean, I think, um,
and then of course, the work related to this,
uh, really delves. AND interprets these data, but a
lot of the evidence coming out, um, of these
efforts are really showing the accumulation of wealth in
the hands of a few. Uh, AND of course,
you know, this is definitely not the most unequal
time in human history and even people who write
about this, like, uh, Thomas Piketty in his earlier
book, um, Capital in the 21st Century shows that
even Pre-World War One, that wealth and income inequality
was greater than it is today. And of course,
you've got this equalizing effect of the, the Boer
Wars and the, and the um aftermath of both
of those. But again, you see the increase in
the 70s and 80s, uh, with the start of
the neo-liberal kind of ideology and reinterpretation of economic
development. Uh HERE we start to see our societies
um Western liberal democracies and throughout the world becoming
more and more unequal, and this trend has continued,
and this is what we see from Piketty in
the early 2010s with his book that again the
wealthy are getting even wealthier at the rate of
returns on capital supersedes. Uh, INCOME increases. Uh, AND
again, this idea that the wealth, wealthy are becoming
wealthy and then the emergence of the super rich.
And of course, then it's, it's more obvious to
see it with the second Trump administration as well.
The role of the super wealthy, they're not trying
to hide it in some way. Elon Musk has
been involved with the re-election. And then with Trump's
second inauguration, we see um all the AI and
the social media company founders, you know, in the
background, a row or 2 sitting behind Donald Trump
in their inauguration. So again, you see the, the
influence of uh of the super wealthy and politics,
uh, in, in this way. And of course, uh,
in the last two or so years, we've seen
how, um, the impact of the second Trump administration,
not just in the United States, but of course
throughout the world.
Yeah, so I, I, I mean, there's at least
something to this worry that some people have that
economic inequality is going up and it's probably having
some detrimental effects across the world, right, because particularly
since the 2020, uh, the COVID-19 pandemic, uh, we've
seen that most of the wealth has flown uh
upwards to the wealthy. I, I mean, some of
the The current richest people in the world like
Elon Musk, Jeff Bezos, and others have, uh, really,
their wealth has really shot up since 2020 and,
uh, not so much, it's, uh, and the trend
has not been the same for people who are
lower in socioeconomic status, right, particularly with uh raising
rising levels of inflation and things like that,
right. Yeah, I mean, I think that's exactly right.
I mean, this is, and you know, when Mosque
a couple of weeks ago, at least temporarily became
the world's first trillionaire, that again, it really symbolizes
this and makes it very accessible for people throughout
the world to show that the world has created
its first trillionaire when many people are struggling, right,
after the things that you said in the post-COVID
world, due to inflation, you know, high cost of
living, and so on.
Yeah, so how about the other view, the sort
of opposite view? What kind of data support the
view that capitalism, even with its associated inequality, has
been beneficial to humanity in terms of lifting people
out of poverty and creating prosperity?
Mhm. And when you look at data from our
world and data, for example, you see that, you
know, in terms of GDP per capita and per
person, um, that we see for most of human
history that people lived, uh, without abundance and prosperity.
Um, THEY lived in poverty, and then with the
advent of the industrial revolution, uh, in the United
Kingdom that Adam Smith talks about, you see this
increase in prosperity, um, around this time, several 100
years ago. But then with this, uh, of course,
increase in prosperity, the movement of people from the
countryside and the cities and so on, you know,
this kind of story of early industrial capitalism, it's
unequal, it's highly polluting, um, and, and so forth,
as I discussed in the book. But with that
comes a rise in prosperity and then with prosperity
created more opportunities for, you know, people to Uh,
to study for universities to grow again, they're unequal
and across many different lines of class and gender,
uh, ethnicity and so forth. But again, uh, throughout
aggregate time and even from the Marxist perspective, Uh,
when people complain about the inadequacies of, of capitalism,
the inequalities of capitalism, uh, you get this redistribution
through people protesting through trade unions and, and so
forth. But over the time, the distribution, um, at
least from this perspective, the distribution of prosperity was
fed back into, uh, uh, into societies, and with
societies, universities began to bloom, the more knowledge was
created with. Knowledge, germ theory, for example, that people
uh were able to create uh different, you know,
vaccines and medical procedures and, and so on. And
of course this feed feedback loop continues, um, knowledge
compounds and with that you get this kind of
redistribution and an aggregate rise in in life conditions
is the argument, uh, for, uh, the link between
capitalism and the increased societal well-being on an aggregate
level.
OK, but when it comes to capitalism lifting people
out of poverty, Iver to arguments that I think
from people who oppose that view that I think
are very compelling, and I would like to hear
your thoughts on them. So the first one has
to do with historically how we classify people as
living in extreme poverty or not, because I mean,
particularly before the In 1800s or so there are
many, there were many societies out there who didn't
even use money, like for example, forager hunter gatherers
and so on, and even in agriculture societies based
on agriculture there were activities there that would sustain
people that didn't really involve money, like for example
the fact that people would have access to a
common land. Where they could farm and they could
feed themselves and their communities without really having or
generating necessarily any wealth when it in terms of
money. I mean there were no, there was no
monetary exchange there. So I mean one critique would
be that, yeah, OK, so you're saying that before
the 1800s, the or the 1700s. Even uh people
had no access to, um, I, I mean, that
most of humanity was living in dire poverty, but
actually if you take those aspects of people's life
ways into account, maybe they were not necessarily not
having access to the basics, uh, uh the uh
the, to the basics of life, let's say so.
And the other critique. I has to do with
the way we calculate extreme poverty. I mean, because
I don't, I'm not sure about the exact amount
that the people from the World Bank and other
places use right now, but until very recently, extreme
poverty was calculated as below $2.15 a day, and
many people have pushed back. On using such a
low amount because, I mean many, most people in
the world, if they would only get $2.15 or
even $3.04 dollars, $5 a day, they would still
not be able to to fulfill their basic needs.
So I mean, do you think there's something to
those critiques or
no? Absolutely. I mean, I think you've hit the
nail on the head with those. I mean, uh,
so yeah, there's the two parts of how we
kind of think about the past, and this is
the importance of again this transdisciplinary perspective that I
tried to discuss and bring into the book, and
the importance of history and, and, uh, historians when
you think and talk about, uh, inequality and capitalism
and so on. So, yeah, this is not to
say when you look at, you know, GDP per
capita from the year zero until, you know, 2026,
uh, when you see this kind of flat line
for, um, Whatever, 17, 1800 years that people there
were living impoverished lives, right? In, in, in this
kind of way that they're just surviving. But of
course people have ways of organizing or sustaining themselves
and of thriving in, in various ways that looks
and feels different. There was a really great book
that was just out. I was reading it over
the summer, a massive book called Capitalism, A Global
History by the Harvard historian Svenn Becker, who looks
at, uh, the early kind of engagement with, uh,
with capitalist enterprises and showing these spikes of inequality
via capitalistic enterprises, but also it's very charming, uh,
history, um, describing, as you've kind of said that,
you know, also people had different ways, and, and
different ways of organizing their economies and thriving in
their, in their own rights. And I, and, you
know, as a cultural psychologist and primarily someone who
uses politics. OF an ethnographic methods. I totally agree
with the second criticism of this, uh, idealized version
of capitalism, lifting people out of, out of poverty,
and that is, it matters what's counted, how it's
counted by whom, and so on. So I think
this is, uh, those people who complain about this
kind of overly simplified narrative of the rising tides,
lift all boats, um, those people who critique that
narrative. They were totally right, uh, on those grounds
as well. So there's something more about kind of
base level of poverty, non-poverty, uh, of GDP and
these kind of figures, and this is something I
try to, uh, critique myself in the book and
develop new ways of thinking about economic development that
are more meaningful for people rather than these blunt,
uh, uh, economic categories, which, uh, I, I think
also kind of predominate, uh, uh, the debate as
well.
So apart from lifting people out of poverty, In
capitalism, or at least people who argue for the
contributions of capitalism also point to, for example, uh,
rising levels of, uh, uh, ever rising educational levels,
elongated and healthier lives. I mean, this kind of,
uh, criticism coming from, uh, for example, socialists and
Marxists, I don't find as compelling as the other
two criticisms. Related to wealth distribution and wealth creation,
but I've also heard people saying that, oh, OK,
those kinds of things were not necessarily the product
of capitalism, they were more the product of the
state, and they could have been achieved through socialism
or through other kinds. Of more equalitarian economic organization
or economic system. So I mean, do you think
that, uh, and then when it comes to healthier
lives, they say that it was mostly through technological
developments and medical advancements that could have been done
even without capitalism. I mean, do you think that
there's any merit. THOSE kinds of criticisms or not.
Yeah,
no, I take these kind of criticisms seriously as
well. Um, BUT I don't conceptualize it as an
either or, right? I mean, if you look at
historically, you're always going to get this dialogical relationship.
If someone asserts that, you deny it. If someone
denies that, you assert it in this way. But
I, you know, I think in the book it's
something I try to trace out again, these tensions
between different kinds of stories, but also between different
theorists, right? I mean, those are kind of more
pro-capitalist. AND think that it's the greatest thing uh
in humanity, and then the kind of more Marxist
side of things where, where people, you know, talk
about communism and these different uh ways of organizing
society, um, and these more egalitarian societies. But of
course, I mean, you know, what I tried to
do in the book, I think when any of
these become kind of like hypercapitalism or really kind
of dictatorial communism, when you reach these extremes, uh,
I'm critical of both, right? Um, I mean, there's
something about I spent some time earlier in my
life, uh, traveling in Cuba, for example, right, where
you have this kind of relatively, uh, egalitarian communist,
uh, type of state. But a lot of people
were poor, and I write about this kind of
personal, you know, travel experience in the book as
well. Uh, A lot of people are poor and
they really kind of wanted to be engaged with
the world, uh, in terms of, you know, commerce,
travel, economics, and, uh, and, and socially as well.
So there's something about societies that You know, have
these kind of top-down communist kind of ideals that
I don't think are, are so great as well.
But then you can contrast it into the, you
know, massive unequal American cities, for example, we have
super rich and then you leave this fancy apartment
building and, and there's poor people, homeless people outside
your door. And I also think that's a problem
as well with the hypercapitalism. So, um, so I
think, you know, I do see this relationship as
kind of dialogical, but I think when it reaches
an extreme one way or the other, it's also
problematic.
Yeah, before we get into how people look at
fairness and unfairness and Uh, uh, contexts of relative
deprivation, which is more about the psychological aspect of
things. Let me just ask you one more question
about economic inequality from an economics perspective. So, um,
I, I mean, I mean, do, do you take
seriously as well the fact that at least according
to, uh, economists who've been studying the Effects of
economic inequality on politics and society. For example, I've
had on the show Dr. Branko Milanovic, who's done
a lot of work on that, and they say
that economic inequality, particularly above a certain level, I'm
not exactly sure about which level exactly, but it
can have negative effects on society and politics, like,
for example, the fact that Uh, billionaires or very
wealthy people can buy politicians and they can make
politicians pass laws and bills that favor them and
then uh or tweak the economic system into money
flowing more upward. Words and there being less redistribution
to the bottom of society or the lower levels
of society and also because of that there's lower,
there's lower opportunity for people at the bottom because
of course people who are wealthy or extremely wealthy.
Uh, HAVE, uh, take, uh, almost all of the
opportunity out there through their, uh, different kinds of
influence. I mean monetary influence, but also the kinds
of connections that they establish and the fact also
that if they influence politics, then the The sort
of the social welfare state gets is affected and
people perhaps public systems and public institutions get worse
and people no longer have access to. For example,
uh, welfare and good public education, good public health
and things like that. So, um, economic mobility goes
down. I mean, do, do you think that those
are issues that we should worry about as well?
Yeah, I mean, I think so. I mean, you
speak about Branko Milanovic, who I've never met, but
I certainly read much of his contributions to our
understanding of economic inequality. I think he's a very
uh big thinker. Uh, I really appreciate that he
takes a global perspective. I think he's right in
some of those ways that you've discussed that there
is, you know, he's not the only one, of
course, talking about the problems of inequality, but I
think he's, he used it so much and he's
kind of omnipresent in the, in the discourse that,
uh, you know, it's OK. TO center on him
and, and this work a little bit. But of
course, yeah, I mean, lots of people have documented
the ill effects of growing economic inequality, particularly in
the kind of this neoliberal hypercapitalistic state as well,
where it's becoming just so obvious, um, to many
people in societies, and, you know, I study primarily
Western liberal democracies, even though in the book I
try to take this kind of global perspective, but
my own kind of ethnographic research, it tends to
focus on Western liberal democracies, but there. Through my
research and, and, and the people I speak to
and, and study, um, that you see that people
are really understanding and seeing clearly some of the
problems of, of inequality, uh, as you rightly say,
with the influence of the super rich on, on
politics, of buying elections, of maintaining, uh, systems that
benefit the status quo, and of course, the status
quo is unequal, and therefore, you know, those who
have, will have more and those who do not
have find it more and more difficult to, uh,
to gain some sort of advantage and, and freedom.
Themselves from their, uh, from their status quo. And
of course, you know, when we maintain the status
quo, when the rich become even richer and so
on, of course, we have this problem with climate
change that's, uh, we can clearly see. I mean,
you're, I guess you're in Portugal, I'm in Copenhagen.
Uh, I was in Pittsburgh over the summer where
we had this kind of sun blocked out from
wildfire smoke in Canada. So wherever you go, you
can see the ill effects of this. And of
course, if you have super wealthy people maintaining How
the system is, the, um, we're going to see
more and more um negative impacts of, of climate
change. Uh, THAT'S it. We, I know we'll speak
a little more about relative deprivation, but when, you
know, people compare themselves to other people and find
themselves disadvantaged, um, through these comparisons, you get more
civic discontent as well. People feel upset, they feel
like they're being left behind, that they're being treated
unfairly in, in some sense. Um, And of course,
we'll take measures to, to feel better. Um, THE
most prominent way of doing that is through voting,
and I guess we'll talk about that, um, some
more, but also more extreme ways in terms of
radical social change in the form of rallies, riots,
and revolutions that I also discussed in the book.
Mhm. Yeah, so talking about relative deprivation, what, what
should we consider here in terms of its effects
on people's psychology and the way we compare ourselves
to other people and how we feel about our
material circumstances? I mean, why is, why is relative
deprivation important?
Mhm. So one of the kind of central tensions
that I explore in the book is this idea
that we live in a world of abundance, in
a world of plenty, but we often feel like
we don't have enough, right? So no matter how
good things are, we never feel like we're quite
where we want to be. So that's the kind
of central psychological test. And one of the central
ways I try to explain it is, as you've
described, through this idea of relative deprivation, which actually
has its origins in sociological field studies uh in
the, in the 1940s, uh, with promotion rates in
the, in the US Army. Um, The theory has
been very generative in different disciplines over the years,
but the bare bones of it is basically that
when an individual or group compares themselves to a
salient individual or group and through that comparison finds
themselves lacking in some way, feeling behind or discriminated
against, then this can lead to angry frustration. Um,
SO that's the kind of bare bones of it,
of course, it manifests in many different ways in
different geographical and cultural, uh, regions and across, uh,
different, um, periods of history as well. Um. So,
you know, this is the core for me in
explaining the psychology of, of how people are feeling
left behind, many hundreds of millions of people feeling
left behind when it comes to, um, uh, the
economic system in which they live in. And, you
know, maybe in, in aggregate GDP objective terms, um,
that people have had it, you know, uh, super
well, right, in, in terms of contemporary societies and
the aggregate, um. Uh, ECONOMIC levels divorced from people's
lived experiences. But when you talk to people and
you figure out how they feel and think about
these, um, uh, economic situations in which they are,
you often get a different story from these people.
Again, this tension between the objective indicators and subjective
realities.
And this sort of, um, psychological effects can lead
to civic unrest, right? I mean, can lead to
people even organizing themselves to protest and sometimes even
protesting violently against this sort of, uh, unfairness that
they perceive in. Society,
right? Yeah, I mean, I think that's absolutely right,
and that was, you know, I think it's nearly
15 years ago. That was my entry point into
this, uh, kind of field of study, right? So
I'm not an economist, I'm a cultural psychologist. And
when I was starting my doctoral dissertation at the
University of Chicago with Richard Schrader, uh, in 2012,
I had this kind of idea. That in Ireland
following the economic collapse in, you know, 2008, 2009,
and the aftermath of this, that, you know, we
had lots of protests and riots in European countries,
including in Portugal and Greece and Spain and Italy,
where people are really upset with the government, uh,
who are overseeing the kind of financial collapse within
their countries. You see it in different parts of
the world and across the EU, but in Ireland,
Where I'm from, we had this much more muted
response that people were not taking to the streets.
They were not protesting. And yeah, you know, so
I was kind of interested in this kind of
comparison of what was going on in Ireland, why
it was so unique, uh, in contrast to some
maybe comparable European Union neighbors who are also suffering
from economic hardship, from austerity, from high unemployment, and
so on. So I wanted to kind of figure
out what was going on. So my initial kind
of studies in 2012 and 2014, 2015 were looking
at some of the kind of cultural and moral
reasons why people in Ireland were not protesting. I
was happily pursuing this line of work when all
of a sudden there are hundreds of thousands of
Irish people out onto the streets protesting during this
period of objective economic growth in Ireland. When our,
you know, our politicians at the time were saying
that, OK, we had austerity in Ireland, things were
really bad, but now things are getting better. Ireland
is once more open for business, we have our
house in order. We were sick, we took our
medicine, like these types of narratives. Uh, BUT then,
you know, regular people were looking around and we
said, hey, I'm hearing these stories that things are
getting better, but I can see it's only getting
better for some people and not other people. In
society and around that same time, the Irish government
introduced this new charge on water. So historically, water
in Ireland was paid through general taxation, but now
the government were putting a specific charge on water
each household consumed, and then people thought this was
incredibly unfair. So this kind of idea of unfairness
was building for some years, this kind of gap
between those improving, those who are not. But then
you have this specific protest symbol, this idea of
charging for water that felt almost like. IRONIC in
Ireland where it's always raining and it's filled with
lakes and rivers and it's an island surrounded by,
uh, by a sea and an ocean, right? So
it felt really weird for people, but really can
consolidate these feelings of unfairness in Ireland. And then
people took to the streets and they protested. So,
I spent a year of my life, uh, following,
um, this protest movement around in its various iterations
and talking to hundreds of people, uh, about these,
um, these feelings that they had. And of course,
They were complaining about the water charge, um, but
when he spoke with them, they had all sorts
of, uh, feelings of, uh, being unfairly treated by
the government or by elites in Ireland or by
the wealthy, and so on. So you kind of
get this, um, division in Irish society that I
was, uh, um, available to document at that time.
And of course, this is one particular case study,
right? Like the Irish case study as a kind
of detail in the book, but then you can
see the same kind of pattern or similar pattern
at least. Uh, ALL around the world, um, and
I write about it in different global regions. Um,
THE Occupy Wall Street movement that, you know, uh,
listeners will remember in the US like didn't occur
when the economy tanked in '07 and 008 in
the United States, but, um, 2011 when it was
clear that during the recovery, that it was the
recovery for the rich and not the rest of
people. So you have that famous trope that we
are the, the 99%, right? So, Uh, then protests
broke out there. You see it in France during
a period of um stark GDP growth, uh, per
capita, but the government introduced this surcharge on fuel
that disproportionately impacted regular people, including truck drivers who
wore the yellow vests, and they went out to
the streets in protest and the famous yellow vest
protest. And I document in the book similar dynamics
in Chile and in Sudan as well.
Yeah, uh, yeah, and, and that's the thing, right,
because even when there's economic growth measured in terms
of GDP growth and even looking at GDP per
capita, we have to be a little bit careful
about how we analyze those numbers because I mean
if there's uh uh it, it's that uh very
common and easy to understand example of if there's
a people. WITH $0 in a room and then
suddenly a billionaire comes in, then everyone there is
a centimillionaire or a deca millionaire or something like
that and I mean that kind of analysis of
course doesn't really tell you at least enough about
people's economic situation. We have, it's better perhaps to
look at. Indicators like PPP and stuff like that
to really have a better understanding of whether uh
the growth of the economy is really improving people's
lives in general or if it's going mostly uh
upward and benefiting the ultra rich,
right. Yeah, I mean, I absolutely agree with you.
This kind of, you know, loops back to what
we discussed a little bit earlier as well. It's
really important how you uh quantify uh these things
and if it's a meaningful quantification in terms of
these objective economic indicators or not. Uh, AND it's
also important of how, you know, policymakers, how politicians
and members of the media are communicating and thinking
about these, um, uh, you know, Bouts of economic
growth or recession or whatever it might be, that's
prevalent in the zeitgeist at the at the time.
Um, BUT what really matters is exactly what you
said, like what people can do, uh, and who
they can be in their, in their lives, right,
in terms of um the money that they have
or finances available to them. What can they do
with that? What kind of lives can they uh
live? And do they think it's fair or unfair,
uh, or not?
Mhm. But when it comes to how people develop
these feelings of unfairness that then eventually can turn
into civic unrest and the other consequences we're going
to talk about, um, I, I mean, because, uh,
I, I want to ask you this because sometimes
people make caricatures about uh feelings of unfairness where
they say that, oh, the, I, I mean, people.
At the bottom, at the bottom of the ladder,
poor people or people from the middle class, uh,
they have enough, they, they're just envious. I mean,
the the reason why they think it's unfair, it's
because it's just because. Uh, THEY don't have as
big a house or as luxurious a car as
the rich people, but it's not really because they
are deprived, it's just because of envy and stuff
like that. But I mean, these feelings of unfairness
are also permeated or influenced by objective economic indicators,
right? I mean, it's not just, oh, I, I
think. Uh, MY society is unfair just because my
neighbor has a Lamborghini or a Ferrari and I
have a Opel or a Citroen or something like
that, right? I mean, it's more, uh, complicated than
those sort of simplified narratives,
right? Yeah, I mean, I think you're absolutely right.
Um, I just recently read Gabriel Zucman's little book
We Need to Tax Billionaires where, uh, you know,
the title kind of says it all. He's getting
a lot of attention. FOR this type of work
and his campaigns. Um, BUT you know, in one
part of the book, he goes through these myths,
these kind of legitimizing myths from billionaires of what
they say to deflect attention from them and to
show that they've earned their success and, uh, and
so forth, right? And then kind of debunks each
of these, these myths. But I mean, there is
something about this kind of, um, envy argument as
well that, you know, in this kind of neoliberal
society, my colleague Thomas Kern at the London School
of Economics writes about this in his book, The
Perfection Trap. And that, you know, no matter how
much we have, we never feel like we have
enough and what's perfect or what's a really good
life. Um, ONCE we try to reach that level,
the level moves up and up, and this is
kind of by design in the neoliberal society as
well. So people who kind of do kind of
feel like they have a lot in their lives
and materially, maybe they're doing pretty well, uh, they
can never really kind of reach where they want
to be as, as well. Um, BUT what I
think is kind of really kind of fascinating, and
as I kind of mentioned earlier, a lot of
what's missing from these types of debates of inequality
is simply, um, uh, the lives of, of poor
people throughout the world. And I think, you know,
one of the complaints, and maybe it's a provocative
complaint in, in the book, is that maybe we're
overly focusing on, um, This idea of, you know,
uh, redistribution and, you know, uh, this idea of
alleviating inequality, because when most people are thinking about
that, they're thinking about inequality in terms of Western
societies that are already quite abundant, um, where, OK,
maybe there's a squeezed middle class and so on.
But I'm hearing, um, or maybe reading not enough,
uh, arguments from, from colleagues and other people who
are writing about this, about the world's poorest people.
There's really great, um, uh, influential book, I think
it was 2015, Harry Frankfurt, a small little book
called On Inequality. He was a, um, was a
professor of philosophy in Princeton, and basically he makes
his argument that I found very convincing is that,
you know, perhaps we're overfocusing on, uh, making the
rich less rich, and what we ought to be
doing is, um, making the poor less poor and
alleviating global poverty is one of the, uh, or
is the moral. PART of our, of our time,
uh, is his argument. And of course, one can
counter argue this and saying by taking from the
billionaires, uh, we can redistribute, uh, and alleviate global
poverty and so on. But, um, the way people
are thinking and talking about, um, this redistribution, it's
not always clear to me that a goal of
redistribution, uh, is to, um, is to help people,
uh, uh, escape or create conditions to help people
escape, uh, global poverty, uh, throughout the world.
Yeah, and the global perspective, I guess, is also
important to keep in mind here, right, because of
course this is not to deny that there are
people in the more developed countries who are really
poor and really deprived, but there's also an argument
to be made that perhaps we should also pay
a little bit more attention to the fact that
the so-called global South. OR people from the so-called
global south are also exploited, at least to a
certain extent in terms of being underpaid to produce
cheap or or products that are sold, that are
sold cheap in more developed countries and so that's
one of the reasons as well why people in
the more developed. Uh, GLOBAL north countries are able
to live, uh, uh, in those, uh, or have
that standard of living,
right? Yeah, I mean, I think that's, that's absolutely
right, and it's not just in the present as
well, right, where you get this kind of, uh,
unequal power relationships and, and, uh, wealthy countries kind
of exploiting the kind of cheaper labor, uh, in
different regions of the world. But I mean historically,
right? I mean this is how a lot of
The countries, as you say, in the so-called global
north, uh, gained this kind of, uh, you know,
wealth advantage and so on. Uh, PEOPLE clearly will
think of the United States and the kind of
basis of slavery at the basis of its capitalistic
enterprises and, and so on. Um, OR, you know,
the UK and England, for example, but also in
Denmark, uh, where I'm from, like, I mean, you
know, whenever I go anywhere, you say you're working
in Copenhagen and, and people talk about What a
lovely city it is, how safe the bike lanes,
the social democracy, all these kind of things, the
stereotypes that come to mind and they're absolutely true,
right? It is a wonderful place to to live
in these ways with various social security nets, protections
and free, free education, healthcare and all those types
of things. But of course, the intergenerational wealth in
countries, uh, Denmark are also predicated on its kind
of colonial past as well and the kind of,
when you talk about Social democracy in this redistribution,
but how it earned its initial wealth to kind
of reinvest in people comes with a very kind
of dark history in places like Denmark and other
countries are spotlights on it. Um, YOU know, I
know Piketty talks about reparations between France and Haiti
and so on. People focus on the United States
and England, but, you know, also there's similar paradoxes
and historical contradictions that are often conveniently ignored in
places like Denmark as well.
Yeah, so let's talk more about the consequences of
people developing these feelings of unfairness and then civic
unrest that might result from that. Is there a
connection between that and the rise of populism and
the slide toward more authoritarianism or even sometimes dictatorship,
but particularly authoritarianism as we've As we've been seeing
rec in recent years in uh Europe and the
US as well uh with people is uh increasingly
supporting uh more far-right figures or figures who have
more authoritarian uh values and policies.
Mhm. Yeah, I mean, I absolutely think so, right?
I mean, I think this has been documented in
multiple ways and across different disciplines, this connection between
uh growing economic inequality that people feel is unfair,
um, how they feel unfairly treated, and so forth,
and then the rise of, um, of populist leaders
and with populist leaders, you open the potential for
them to become, uh, dictators, right? Um, And you
can see this, you know, throughout the world. I
mean, obviously most famously in, in the United States
with the, the election of Donald Trump in the,
in the first term. But what you saw in
the United States following like the Occupy protests, the
unequal recovery from the financial recession, and so on,
but, you know, some people were benefiting, um, having
good lives, and other people are feeling left behind,
and you can see this in sociology, this, the
famous book, Strangers in Our Own Land, um, uh,
documenting these kind of people in Not in the
east, west coast, cosmopolitan, uh, uh, maybe economically progressive
regions of the United States, but you know, in
the kind of heartland of America who are feeling
like they did not belong to their country. They
felt disconnected from centers of power, uh, from where
the decisions are being made. They felt, you know,
uh, overlooked, unfairly treated, discriminated against, and so on.
Um, AND then, you know, you, you get the
The emergence of this character of Donald Trump, who
really kind of feels and understands this, um, and,
and takes advantage of it, you know, through his
early political campaigning, his rallies, and so on, creating
this kind of cohesive in-group identity, identity that, you
know, he's with them, he supports his regular workers
who feel unfairly treated or disenfranchised in different ways.
Uh, AND then, of course, we all know the
story that when he comes to power in this
way. Uh, DURING the first, uh, election of it.
Then of course, when Biden comes in, you know,
in terms of the classic complaint was that although
the economy again improved under Biden and, and, and
people were wealthier than ever at the time in
the United States, it wasn't fairly um felt. Or
evenly distributed by the people. And again, that created
even more fertile ground for, uh, in an age
of abundance that it's unfairly distributed. And then again,
Trump comes back in once more. And we can
see this kind of pattern, you know, all over
the world as well, um, with the, with the
election of kind of populist leaders. Boris Johnson in
the UK and and and so on. But of
course, you know, there's alternatives that open up, you
know, I mean, Trump takes advantage, but an alternative
possibility with someone like Bernie Sanders, who's a populist
on kind of more of a left wing populist,
right, who probably would have been better, at least
in an economic sense. Um. Uh, HAD he been,
uh, got the nomination from the Democratic Party to
run as president, uh, instead of Clinton, Hillary Clinton,
uh, in this way, maybe he was better for
the people who ultimately voted for Trump. So I
mean, it opens up the inequality, opens up the
possibility for different styles of leaders and different forms
of government as well. But what happens, you know,
you've asked about populism and it's linked to authoritarianism,
but what happens when people come to power. Uh,
THEY promise, like, as I've described in one of
my papers with Bob Sternberg and Arazu Dastaki and
Cornell University, they promise a wonderland. They promise this
kind of shortcut to solve all your problems of
feeling disrespected, unfairly treated. They promise all these things,
and yet when they come to power, they're often
corrupt. They often don't really help the people that
they say they will help, and they often You
know, grow inequality and create systems that benefit them
and people like them rather than, you know, tens
of millions of people who voted for them as
well. And you can see this pattern. So again,
you get, you know, this promised wonderland, and then
you get the emergence of these toxic leaders who
do not improve a lot for people in their
country and also do not do it for humanity
more broadly.
Yeah, and the thing is that that can also
connect to the erosion of civic rights of human
rights, because they also tend to resort to these
oversimplistic and mostly false narratives where they come up
with a scapegoat. I mean, usually it's the Immigrants,
but sometimes it's also even poor people or people
who are on welfare in their own countries, LGBTQ
people, sometimes it's even women, sometimes it's the left
in general where they say that, oh, it's not
the people in power, it's not the rich, it's
not people. With influence that are screwing you up,
it's basically those minorities that are really screwing the
system, and you should place yourself against them. You
should be against them and you should vote for
the conservative right or the far right because those
are the real culprits here, right?
Yeah, I mean, I think, and it also kind
of, you know, really taps into classic uh experimental
social psychology, right? It's kind of in-group, out-group, people
want to have a kind of a cohesive in-group
of, for example, Trump is a leader, and he's
very kind of a large group of followers, for
example, that you need an out-group with a common
enemy and so on. I mean, the common enemy
with Trump is, of course, uh immigrants, right? Um,
AND that's, you know, you demonize them as an
out-group, and you can see it happening with the
rise of the far right in the UK, uh,
murmurs, murmurings, and some reality in Ireland, where I'm
from, in Germany as well, right? You get these
kind of outgroup of, uh, of immigrants who any
kind of issues or whatever it might be are
exaggerated or exploited and so on, by these far
right leaders. And of course, you know, on the
other hand, with left wing populists, you get the
same kind of uh attempt at least with uh
uh forming an outgroup, you know, for example, Uh,
billionaires, uh, wealthy elites, and so on who are
not in your interests or whatever it might be,
right? You kind of get the same kind of
thing that people do not represent you and people
like you. Um, BUT I think the last decade
has shown us that, uh, the right wing populace
over the left wing populace have been, uh, quote
unquote, more successful in, um, uh, informing their outgroup
that the drum up hate and draw up the
attention, support, and even love, uh, for them.
Uh, WHAT is the equality difference paradox that you
talk about in your book?
Yeah, so this is something I first came across
in, in grad school at the University of Chicago,
uh, via Rick Schrader and, uh, Michael Jindra, who's
a cultural anthropologist. Um, SO over the years, different
people have been writing about it in different ways,
but the bare bones of it basically. Of the,
of the paradox is that countries uh that have
relatively um high levels of uh ethnic and racial,
religious diversity, um, when you're high on those categories,
you also tend to have high income inequality. Uh,
SO think of places like the United States that
are Very diverse, uh, racially, ethnically, religiously, and so
on, also has high inequality. Um, AND in contrast,
countries that have, uh, low levels of income inequality,
uh, places like Denmark, for example, also tend to
have, uh, low levels of, uh, of racial and
ethnic, um, Diversity. So it kind of presents this
kind of uh um tension, right? Um, THE paradox
between do you value diversity and multiculturalism, allowing immigrants
and migration and a plurality of different values of
life. If that's the case, then you might also
then have to accept some levels of income inequality
between groups, uh, because different groups have different, uh,
Um, income and wealth starting points, for example, but
they also have different economic aspirations as well. Not
all groups, cultural groups, value the accumulation of, uh,
of wealth and, and income, uh, to the same
degree as other groups. But the other side of
the tension then as well is that If you
value, um, or if you value economic inequality like
you do in places like Denmark, uh, one way
to maintain this inequality, um, is to maintain cultural
uh homogeneity, um, and not leave in immigrants and
not, uh, accept, um, uh, refugees or asylum seekers,
for example.
But, uh, uh, I mean, is there enough evidence
to say that the societies who are more homogeneous
in terms of ethnicity, for example, um, I mean
that that there's less uh civic unrest there or
not.
No, I don't know if I would go that
far. I mean, it's a descriptive correlation, but when
you see it presented, and I presented in the
book, I mean, it is quite a stark, um,
especially in countries where there's money, uh, more wealthier
countries where there is a possibility of redistributing, uh,
uh, uh, finances, right? Um. But yeah, you see
this kind of correlation. You can see the Scandinavian
countries and Eastern Europe kind of clustered together. It's
a very specific way where there's low income inequality,
uh, but also low uh homogeneity, uh, and then
other places where it's, you know, high, uh, inequality
and high diversity, uh, as well. So, I mean,
I think it's open for further empirical work, but
I thought, you know, as a descriptive correlation, it's
really interesting and it helped me frame some of
the discussions I have towards the end of the
book. I mean, one of the kind of things
that we hear a lot about, um, in, in
Scandinavia and Denmark in particular is this kind of
high level of social democracy and the redistribution of
wealth and how, you know, things are pretty good
here. But the kind of dark side of Scandinavian
societies is that it comes with this kind of
uh um Closed-mindedness, I would say, to, uh, to
having immigrants, uh, refugees and asylum seekers, uh, come
into Denmark. Um, SO it's the redistribution is predicated
on sameness, on this kind of shared imagined community
that if I pay taxes, and other people who
are like me reap the benefits of those taxes
and vice versa down the lines. So when, you
know, newcomers come, um, they often feel like they're,
you know, excluded from. From this system or with
with it comes heavy levels of assimilation that one
ought to become, um, in a very quick way,
uh, think like, act like and speak like the
host nation as well. And that stands in contrast
to the United States, for example, right, where there's
a plurality of worldviews, values, languages that are spoken
as well. And with that, uh, different views of
economic development and, and, uh, uh, visions for living
the good life.
So let's talk a little bit about how we
should think and theorize about the future, and this
is not about predicting the future, but more about
how we should theorize about it and consider the
different possibilities out there. So in the book you
explore three different possibilities. The first one has to
do with, I mean, basically what The left has
been worrying about, about the possibility of continued exponential
economic inequality and aggravating climate change and the planet
becoming more uninhabitable, more unequal, more unfair, and things
like that. So, um, how should we explore that
possibility?
Yeah, I mean, I think um this is one
of the kind of maybe unusual parts of the
book, kind of you're trying to end it by
mapping out potential futures. As you rightly say, these
are definitely not predictions, but, you know, just to
kind of present plausible future narratives to readers of
the book and as the ideas echo through to
kind of have these kind of possibilities for people.
As you say, possibility one, is this kind of,
uh, uh, maintenance of the status quo, the rich
getting richer, they have disproportionate influence on politics, uh,
on climate and climate change, and, and so on.
Uh, WITH the rich getting richer again, as we
discussed, we get the civic discontent, uh, so more
likely the, the rise of, um, populist and authoritarian
leaders. As well to mitigate it. But of course,
you know, um, and how we think about this,
I mean, it's, I think it's a distinct possibility
because even since I wrote it and drafted it,
whatever it was two years ago, we can see
further evidence of its continuation, uh, as well, with
how, you know, Trump and, and, and so on,
uh, is impacting the, the world. So I think
it's Becoming self-evident, um, that this possibility is, is
living out. But what we're also seeing is kind
of counter voices and people are trying to think
about different ways of, uh, organizing, uh, uh, economic
development of thinking about morality and human development, and
so on. So we're seeing kind of, you know,
growing kind of counter voices in a different direction,
uh, as well.
And the second possibility is basically almost the opposite
one. So that has to do with even if
there's still economic inequality, we prize the creation of
greater economic inequality. So what do you think we
should examine when it comes to this second possibility?
Yeah, I mean, I think that the first possibility,
for example, it becomes so extreme and, you know,
so real for people, uh, that it calls for
a counter opposite. And this is kind of what
I'm seeing with the main ideas that are contrasting
uh possibility one from possibility two. TRY to group
them together under the kind of banner of equality
now. People who want to end economic inequality, they
think it's the worst thing in the world? Uh,
WHAT are the kind of ideas in equality now?
I mean, One of them that I, I talk
about is this emerging policy of de-growth, uh, which
I think rightly, you know, the idea of kind
of purposefully slowing down and de-growing aspects of the
economy, right, that that disproportionately impact uh the climate
and, and lead to the climate change that we're
seeing as well. Uh, SO I think there's a
right diagnosis there. Um, I think, you know, some
aspects obviously of the economy are really detrimental, uh,
to causing, uh, climate change and leading to climate
change. But I think overall the policy of de-growth
as a way of creating equality, I mean, it
comes with the loss of hundreds of thousands, maybe
millions of jobs and different ideas that there's something
about kind of like, uh, making people unemployed and
not kind of thinking about these possible futures by
this kind of argument that we must end inequality
now is a little, I think, unbecoming. I don't
think the solution quite, um, is congruent with the
diagnosis of the problem. Uh, OTHER possibilities you hear
kind of more communist or kind of socialist, uh,
forms of government that will introduce suites of policies,
um, to make, uh, equality, uh, more of a
reality. I, I present some examples, uh, of the
downfalls of, of communism and this way of thinking,
uh, in the book, if we look at China
under Mao, for example, and the so-called Great Leap
Forward, and these types of issues. Report, you know,
some writings and experiences with Cuba, these communist regimes
where things were not so good for, you know,
tens and hundreds of millions of ordinary people. Socialism,
as I've tried to articulate with the Danish example,
comes with a dark side as well. It's not
also rosy when he keeps these social democracies. So
I kind of cluster those in this kind of
equality now. I mean, probably the one that You
know, has probably most legitimacy is the idea of
taxing, right, and redistributing through taxing. A lot of
people are talking about this, you know, I mean,
there's obviously different arguments for what is fair and
unfair rates of taxation. I think it differs in
different kind of cultural contexts as well. Uh, THE
rate of taxation in Copenhagen is a lot higher
than in Chicago where I previously lived, uh, and
people will think about fairness in different ways. Given
our unique cultural context, uh, and the kind of
master narratives at the basis of their societies that,
uh, that differ, right? So I think, um, this
is something to keep in mind. But out of
the suites of kind of creating more, uh, equality
within countries, I think taxation in a form that
people seriously think about progressive taxation and take seriously
ideas of fairness and unfairness, uh, is one perhaps
meaningful way forward.
And then the third possibility is perhaps the most
interesting one because we don't hear about it often.
That has to do with the implementation of ethical
pluralism. What is ethical pluralism in this context of
economic inequality?
Yeah, so kind of, it's basically this idea that
what people think is good and bad, and right
and wrong, uh, varies systematically throughout the world and
across time. So again, kind of drawing on this
kind of cultural psychological theorizing. Um, SO when it
comes to ethics and what is good and right
to do in relation to developing the economy and
how we think about our financial systems and, uh,
and people's lives within those economic worlds, um, The
idea is that it now looks like and likely
will into the future, um, people will draw on
different forms of ethics of what is good and
bad, right and wrong, to develop, uh, these particular
economies, um, and different ways of distribution and redistribution
of innovation and entrepreneurialship and so on. So the
idea with uh ethical Pluralism based on kind of
value pluralism that people have different kind of values,
right? Uh, AND different desires and wants, uh, and
this varies systematically in different cultural regions throughout the,
throughout the world. Um, SO the idea of this
kind of part of the book is going to
lay some kind of foundations for how we think
about the plurality of different economic systems into the
future, but also the Provide some guidelines, like some
ethical guidelines, uh, despite the non-uniformity, uh, of them,
uh, but that might help guide, um, you know,
citizens, policymakers, governments, um, to think about, uh, ways
to improve their economies into the future that are
congruent with, um, these ethical principles based in cultural
histories and master narratives.
Yeah, and finally, with that in mind, you suggest
three principles in your book, right? Creating fairness, escaping
from poverty, and pursuing human capability. So could you
explain those principles and how they tie with ethical
pluralism, perhaps?
Mhm. Yeah, I mean, one of the things I
think we're kind of missing perhaps in this kind
of moment. History is maps for the future and
guidance of, of where we go. Um, SO I
end the book with this kind of articulation, as
you've said, this idea of alleviation of poverty from
all my reading on, you know, psychology, economics and
poverty and all these different disciplines. I think it's
so ignored this, this role of, of, of, uh,
uh, of global poverty and its alleviation. I think
for me, like Harry Frankfurt when I first Read
this little philosophy book. I think, I think it's
a moral imperative of our time to help, um,
alleviate, um, global poverty. I mean, maybe one of
the ways I can, you know, I can see
from growing up in Ireland, as I write in
the book, I was born in 1985 and I
have this memory, uh, of my initial years of
Ireland being a poor country, right? Um, AND then
it was with EU funding through the 19. Uh,
LATE 1990s and 2000s that the country, you know,
it's kind of the stimulus package or where people
were working and universities were getting more money, education
became free, you know, the kind of, you get
this kind of injection of, uh, of, of financing
based on the EU and it kind of led
to this more capitalistic enterprises and increased a lot
of people in Ireland and now it's one of
the wealthiest countries in the world. Um. But I
can see this when it comes to alleviation of
poverty, right? I mean, there's other countries that I
can see that are poor now. I read that
Sierra Leone, for example, in the book in different
sections, but there's no reason why. Uh, THERE'S a
possibility for these countries in a relatively short historical
period of time to also escape, uh, uh, poverty
through innovation or developing their economies. You know, we
mentioned Branko Milanovic earlier on, and he writes in
one of his books about the great escape of
India and China, uh, from, um, Uh, uh, from,
uh, poverty, right, um, and the lifting of hundreds
of millions of people in those countries out of
poverty, but via capitalistic enterprises, and there's no reason
other countries can't do this. But to your question
about ethical pluralism, it'll look different in different parts
of the world. Um, BUT I do think the
You know, there's something to be said about, um,
not just, you know, distributing aid or having people
migrate and send remittances and so on, even though
I think these things are important, but also to
kind of build up their local economies, um, in
ways that are meaningful and useful, uh, in, in
places that are currently poor is something that's important.
Then of course we talk about fairness as we've
already described quite a lot. I mean, this idea
of fairness and creating sense and narratives of fairness,
tends to be something that's very important. Uh, PEOPLE
get upset when they think it's violated, no matter
how good things are. Uh, IF it's not feeling
like, uh, You're on the, you're in the right
place, uh, in your societies, um, I think people
will be upset. So I think kind of creating
a greater sense of fairness that might come with
a more fair distribution of economic surplus, uh, something
that really ought to be on people's agendas. Then
the final issue is human capabilities, and here I'm
drawing on Martha Nussbaum, who's a um a legal
scholar and philosopher at the University of Chicago who's
going to really develop this kind of human capabilities
approach, which is really predicated on two main questions.
Um, AND she's also critiquing these mainstream economic indicators
of growth and, and non-growth and so on. Uh,
SHE talks about who can people be. And what
can we do in the societies in which they
live, and this should be the focus point for
policymakers and governments and for citizens to be concerned
with above and beyond the issues with aggregate economic
growth, but actually regular citizens throughout the world in
different societies. He should have these set of principles,
uh, where he can be, who do you want
to be and, and to try and do and
pursue the things that they find meaningful in their
cultural context. So again, the book ends not with
specific kind of, you know, uh, policy recommendations or
specific implementation in whatever country people are interested in,
but rather it's kind of a broad mapping of
the potential. POSSIBILITIES, um, for future avenues and within
the third possibility, uh, these guidelines that will look,
and be implemented in different ways, but hopefully people
can find some inspiration to get out of the
kind of current quagmire we kind of find ourselves
in with these discussions of inequality and have a
roadmap for, uh, perhaps a brighter, gentler future.
Very interesting. So the book is again in equality,
A View from many wars, and of course I
will be leaving a link to it in the
description of the interview. And Dr. Power, apart from
the book, would you like to tell people where
they can find you and your work on the
internet?
Yeah, sure. Um, I guess you can just Google
my name, uh, Seamus Power or Seamus Apower.com is
my personal website. University of Copenhagen, Seamus Power, uh,
will, will get my academic profile at the University
of Copenhagen. So you can, you can find, uh,
lots of links to my papers and some uh
reviews of the book and, and so on. So,
uh, I'm highly Googleable at this stage, I think.
Well, thank you so much for taking the time
to come on the show. It's been a really
fascinating conversation, and of course, I couldn't recommend the
book enough to my audience. Please go and buy
it. It's really a fascinating book and it's been
great to talk with you.
Thanks so much, Ricardo. I appreciate it.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Muller, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingberrd, Arnaud Wolff, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forst Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inai Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoras and
Hal Herzognun, Machael Jonathan Labrarith, John Yardston, and Samuel
Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezaraujo Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Punteran Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis Nico Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alekbaka Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov, Zal
Adrian Yei Poltonin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward Hall,
Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolati, Gabriel Pancortez or
Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony Smith, and
Wisman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno, Luke
Lovai, Georgios Theophannus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David Williams,
Dio Costa, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw, Marie
Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee Jr.
Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert Grassy,
Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark Kempel,
Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson, Benjamin
Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael Bensleyman.
George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate von Goler,
Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi, Perpendicular,
Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov, Sean
Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special thanks
to my producers is are Webb, Jim Frank Lucas
Stink, Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas
Trumbull, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlomon Negro, Al
Nick Cortiz and Nick Golden, and to my executive
producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie.
Thank you for all.